should we close it out with the King
under sting it oh yeah man that burger
hit me in the neck thing I didn't know I
thought we were picking which one is
which company and then so that's what I
tasted them all thing in that I just
wanted to prove if you did or didn't
like in and out it been hilarious I
picked in and out number one but we both
been dead last that crazy
yeah Wow here we go I got a king and her
stinger for you boys
the Rat King watching over you on that
throne while you're dropping down a
hitter amen brother Gang Gang buzz buzz
the Rat King watching people think [ __ ]
praise God Bravo why not a little art in
there goes a long ways yep I think if
you can look at some art or something
inspiring while something's coming out
of your butt then you deserve to be able
to do it well sometimes you gotta push
through sometimes it's tough to get it
out and if you look up there and you
feel probably did this you know yeah
yeah I think if you got yeah if you look
at a nice art doesn't cocaine make you
constipated I don't think so I finally
they me go to the bathroom no is it the
opposite that's what people go do it in
the bathroom cuz they're in there doing
and I'm doing duties doing I thought it
made you super constipated I don't think
so I think if you do pills for like oh
that's right pills a long time then you
can't go to the toilet but people I
think people go to the toilet too much
anyway I probably poop maybe two times a
week 73% said King eat good choices
27% had issues with it what else do you
want over your bathroom toilet what is
it some picture of like a boat yeah you
know art is to [ __ ] on a sailboat it's
extremely hard oh man people who have
posters that says live laugh love on
them oh yeah alright yeah if you're
single do you walk in a girl's room it
says live laugh love you know what's
going down
[Laughter]
is that one yeah
[Music]